ils parsèment le paysage canadien depuis
plus d'un siècle
pour bien des autochtones ces symboles
du passé des cicatrices douloureuses
doivent disparaître je voulais mettre le
feu parce que c'est pas des bons
souvenirs que j'ai eu des echards
kistabish ancien chef de la première
nation abitibiwinni et aux survivants
des pensionnats le coh utilisant les
bâtiments dans lesquels
des histoires d'horreur qu'on pouvoir
faire la job de recouvrir de revitaliser
notre langue ou de remettre en place
mais disposition fondamentaux de notre
culture mais démolir peut s'avérer un
processus très long et coûteux le
gouvernement fédéral annonce donc 100
millions de dollars en deux ans pour
financer ces destructions dans les
communautés qu'ils souhaitent les deux
ne sont pas identiques il ya une volonté
d'un certain niveau de détruire et de
passer à autre chose il ya dans do une
volonté de préserver l'édifice est
d'avoir un site qui honore la mémoire
des victimes
waouh
ça ne sera pas suffisant de démolir
souligne la chef de l'assemblée des
premières nations qui étaient présentes
pour l' annonce la question c'est quel
et vous bâtir à la place
dawa indique d'ailleurs aux communautés
qu'elles pourront se servir de l'argent
pour reconstruire sollicite et
l'intérieur culture va aider
facilitez vous ouvre les portes ministre
fédéral de la justice nomme également un
interlocuteur spéciale qui devra
déterminer comment répondre aux
communautés qui souhaite une enquête sur
les crimes commis dans les pensionnats
les conservateurs parlent d'une avancée
ils étaient 1 qui se passe quelque chose
mais ce qui est annoncé aujourd'hui qui
est un pas dans la bonne direction c'est
pour d'autres c'est insuffisant d'autres
demandes c'est une enquête merci ou
poursuivre en justice les gens
responsables
est ce qu'on est capable de faire plus
et ce qu'on est capable de faire plus un
avis partagé par richard kistabish les
pitchous moque il ya c'est de se
démerder hier celle de se sortir de ce
scandale difficile de ne pas voir de
lien entre l'annoncé aujourd'hui et les
rumeurs d'élections qui s'intensifiait
ottawa les libéraux veulent sans doute
montrer qu'ils agissent sur une de leur
premier sport surtout que la pression
populaire s'accentue depuis la terrible
découverte de kamloops et de toutes
celles qui ont suivi ici le rend
certains radio canada ottawa